[Music]
Alysha I gotta ask you about JT oh
that's right we've been wanting to do a
song together for a minute and I
remember even we you know we've done
some songwriting together and everything
like that and and there's more to come
because we're we have so much synergy
you know he I love his I love how he
creates you know he's very very very
passionate about what he does he's
really inside of himself and inside of
the music and it's just it's just like
me so it's it's it's so fresh that we
have this song together on his album
that's coming which is crazy yeah what
can you I love this record man I really
feel like he's every time he comes I
feel like he finds a new place of
himself you know and I love the way he
just like slightly pushes the boundary a
little bit more and it's the it's the
best way to be so I'm excited for him
y'all gonna love this record Alisha's
collaboration with Justin Timberlake is
featured on his new album man of the
woods but first she's teaming up with
Shawn Mendes as her celebrity advisor
for the upcoming season of The Voice
Wow like that what copy were you
drinking
I don't Jamaica whatever she has but I
do like the screen and show especially
about tak which is pretty outrageous
yeah
Shaun tell me about your reaction when
you got the call that Alicia wanted you
to participate this season I was like I
feel like I should be getting in front
of the microphone and singing like and
asking her for advice so there's some
young people on this team and I think
it's nice to hear from somebody you know
really close to your age being like I
have the same feeling I feel the same
way you know like I think one thing that
we both kind of said is like you don't
get on stage and you just do you have to
kind of think about it and it's hard
work and you have to make it amazing you
have to believe in yourself and I think
them hearing them that from like both of
our angles is really helping them
[Music]